[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Музей]
[Закарпаття, Калина
Музей]
У селі я Юрій Іванович,
а в моєму українському паспорті —
Дордь Яношович.
[Юрій Куцин
Засновник музею села Калина]
А в Москві в мене два закордонні,
я Цезар Маріконе.
Тож до мене ви не придеретеся.
В мене і телефон тут, домашній, засекречений.
Коли був Брєжнєв, то я помагав комунізм будувати.
А як Горбачов — я помагав розвалювати.
Я був три години із Горбачовим Михаїлом
Сергійовичем на шашлику, так, як тепер з вами.
Я водій , я столяр,
я художник, я винахідник,
я конструктор —
ну можу все, що завгодно.
Це стіл. За нього сідала родина,
тут наливали, насипали і їли.
Якщо була одна дитина — їла з такого.
Якщо було п'ять-шість дітей — їли з такого.
Якщо було 10-15 — то з цього.
Оце — чоловічий петик.
Чоловіки носили.
Оце — светр.
Носила наречена взимку,
коли холодно.
Це з кролика, з пуху.
Це брали в оренду.
А це чоловіча гуня [верхній одяг],
це — жіночі гуні,
це — вишиванка з бісером.
Це намисто називається зґарда.
Це — молода наречена.
Вранці, коли весілля закінчувалося,
оцю приймитку і цей вінок знімали,
надягали таку чорну приймитку,
що означало, що це вже заміжня жінка.
Розпочинається у неї чорне життя.
Я одружився...
Я, як закінчив школу,
шукав дівчину, сватав, на чотирьох селах.
Усіх дівчат на селі перебрав, оця, ця
не подобається, ця крива, ця пузата,
у цієї — ноги не такі,
і потім,
взяв ту, що мама казала.
Оцю.
Золоте весіля з бабою вже відсвяткували.
На вулиці, в дворі, потім — в музеї,
потім тут столи клали, сиділи,
тут були два музичні гурти.
Ніхто такого весілля не робив ні сто років тому,
ні сто років вперед таке весілля
ніхто не робитиме.
♪ [грає варган] ♪
Це тільки що я їздив так.
А дома — я ж лишав жінку!
І ви думаєте, що то так просто?
Я, оце, як їхав —
залишав на трьох чоловіків.
Тому платив, тому платив і тобі платив.
Щоб турбувалися, щоб наглядали.
Щоб як хтось піде у відрядження — ще два,
якщо й той поїде — третій дивиться.
А що ви думаєте — я платив чоловікам.
Це глобус, я зробив на пам'ять.
От, музей «Калина», де ми зараз.
Це всі країни — зверху і вниз від екватора,
в яких я побував.
76 країн світу.
Я був в Індії на трьох весіллях.
На багатому був, на середньому і на бідному.
Та там індійка одна як притиснулася до мене,
то в мене пішло тисяча вольт!
Ви розумієте, це, як той трактор С100,
що викорчовує коріння, то все рветься.
Я був усюди, будував усе. Від А до Я.
У В'єтнамі я шість місяців будував
військовий аеропорт імені Хошиміна.
В Ірані — три місяці на Буширській атомній станції.
На Мальті був
у дипломатичних справах.
Я був зв'язковим.
Мені треба було виходити на зв'язок з людиною.
Передавати і приймати коди.
Я не знав, що зроблю музей.
Спочатку хотів робити
профілакторій алергологічний.
Асматиків лікувати сіллю, ропою.
Або музей, або профілакторій,
я зупинився на музеї.
Це пральна машина «Карпати-3».
Це « Карпати-2»,
а «Карпати-1» — оцей пралник.
Це на річці прали.
І наркотики я перевозив.
В Індії — ми їздили...
але з нами була їхня охорона,
їхнє КДБ.
Два такі молоді хлопці.
А раз ми їдемо в автобусі, а вони жують.
Жують щось.
Кажу: «Хлопці, а що ви жуєте?»
А вони: «На, й ти жуй».
— А що це таке?
— Наркотик.
«Ой, ні. Ноу-ноу».
А потім, десь через два дні —
ану, дайте спробувати.
Я взяв, спробував.
— А де то продається?
— Треба в боса питати.
Я купив п'ять пачок.
Та так, жував, іншим давав.
Дав одному начальнику, бо він питав:
«Іванович, а що ти там жуєш?»
Ну я витягнув пару зерняток,
він то пожував, поїхав,
прийшов додому,
а дружина теж повернулась з роботи.
І питає його: «Ти що, пив?»
І приходить рано він на роботу, питає:
«Юрію Івановичу,
ти знаєш, як мене жінка [сварила]?
Що це було?
Я такий веселий, такий бадьорий став після цього».
Я кажу: «Наркотик».
Це ліхтарик.
Сюди заливали гас.
Якщо ви йшли сам, світили собі.
Якщо йшла з вами коханка,
відкривали і їй, щоб і вона бачила.
♪ [грає варган] ♪
Це герб України.
А тут в мене був серп і молот. Російський.
І ось приходять до мене туристи, і я кажу:
«Це герб України, а це Союзу,
серп і молот».
Одного разу прийшов
один турист із західного боку
і каже: «Це не серп і молот. Це смерть і голод».
Я замовчав і задумався.
Адже ж чоловік мав рацію.
Коли Ленін Союз закрутив,
це ж було і в Франції, і повсюди революція.
У кожну хату голод зайшов.
І смерть була.
Цей чоловік казав правильно.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператор
Дмитро Охріменко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажерка
Ліза Литвиненко]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy, DakhaBrakha,
Tik Tu, Sahsa Boole, Іван Лузан]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]